this is Monday November 7th one day
until the 2016 presidential election
between Hillary Clinton former Secretary
of State and Donald Trump whose
spokesperson told CNN last night that a
jay-z video shows him throwing Mazel Tov
cocktails and this is the closer it was
in the New York Times yesterday it was
about Stephen Miller senior Trump policy
advisor and Corey Lewandowski fired
Trump campaign manager meeting with
Trump campaign chief executive Steven
Bannon
it was Friday October 28th Manchester
New Hampshire and they had just read the
letter from FBI director Comey the
letter that could still throw the
election to Trump not the letter
yesterday that was an attempt to save
commis ass and the asses of the fascists
who have reportedly caused the FBI's New
York office to go rogue advisor Miller
and fired campaign manager Lewandowski
and this baboon Bannon were trying to
figure out what Trump should say in a
speech just minutes away when it
happened as The Times wrote it quote as
the aides agonized over which words to
feed into the teleprompter they became
so engrossed that a hot light set up
next to the machine caused mr. bannon
school hiking pants to begin smouldering
I think my pant leg is on fire he said
after noticing the acrid smell and quote
the chief of this Friday the 13th movie
marathon of a presidential campaign and
his pants are literally on fire Trump
when the go-to metaphor about lying in
the world they go to metaphor about
political lying in the world suddenly
happens for reals - your campaign chief
executive in something just this side of
spontaneous combustion Trump when your
campaign Chiefs clothing becomes liar
liar pants on fire
imagery analysis probity have all lost
their ability to correctly qualify or
even quantify your campaigns dishonesty
you have defied description you have
eluded art you have beggared the
imagination Trump your campaign you and
everything around you are simply a
another lie another [ __ ] Trump lie
the first Comey letter the worst attempt
to throw the election by a government
agency since a morals charge against an
LBJ aide in October 1964 was supported
by a letter from gosh the FBI and your
exploitation zuv an exploitation is now
rendered pathetic and transparent by
commis desperate second letter yesterday
Clinton's gonna be indicted Clinton's
going to jail Clinton would be impeached
each one of those a lie another lie
another [ __ ] Trump lie and that was
hardly the worst of the lies just this
weekend on Friday at a North Carolina
Clinton rally a protester interrupted
President Obama the crowd booed the
older man but the president told them
his own side to quote sit down and be
quiet for a second he then told them to
respect their elders and to respect that
man's rights and the uniform that he was
wearing which suggested he was a veteran
that night in Pennsylvania though you
Trump claimed Obama quote spent so much
time screaming at this protester and
frankly it was a disgrace a lie another
lie another [ __ ] trump lie the next
night in Reno you Trump upped the ante
about the president and the protestors
quote it was a really bad scene let me
tell you the way he acted that's right
before a guy unveils a Republicans
against Trump sign and you say we have
one of those guys from from the Hillary
Clinton campaign how much are you being
paid $1,500 all right taking out your
crowd promptly takes him out he is
jumped punch he says he was grabbed by
the groin and then Trump somebody in
your crowd says gun a lie another lie
another [ __ ] trump lie there was no
gun just a guy with a sign getting
beaten up by your crowd
Secret Service rush you off the stage
fine good bless them glad we haven't
descended to violence against the
candidates but while you are lying Trump
about how Obama handled a
protester you incited your own crowd to
beat up a protester and then the special
projects director of a group called
citizens for Trump promptly tweets
Hillary ran away from rain today Trump
is back on stage minutes after an
assassination attempt a lie another lie
another trump lie and that lie was
promptly retweeted by your son
idiot jr. and your own social media
director dance Covino your people turned
a guy with a sign into an assassination
attempt and then at your next speech
Saturday night in Denver the priest
introducing you says you just survived a
murder attempt a lie another lie another
[ __ ] trump line from a priest
the next morning confronted on CNN with
this succession of Trump lies your
campaign manager Kellyanne Conway
refuses to back away from the lie that
this was an assassination attempt
instead of what it really was a piece of
cardboard but she does complain about a
list of CNN's stories she doesn't like
and she offers to trade quote you guys
retract that I will give a call to dance
Covino about the retweet not oh thank
goodness there was no assassination
attempt just a lie another lie drop by
this weekend Trump was an unintentional
and almost complete preview of what a
trump presidency would be like you and
your little fascist friends like Rudy
Giuliani manipulating the levers of
government to try to win elections
presenting to everyone a universe
designed to replace truth with imaginary
menaces and phony assassination attempts
and political prosecutions and the
demonizing of criticism and the insane
defiance of reality lies instead of
truth lies instead of reality lies
instead of life and yet with all of
these lies the biggest lie of the
weekend Trump nearly flew under
everybody's radar it is impossible to
say for sure just how far you would go
to punish undocumented Americans you've
already insisted millions of them will
be deported there are laws on the books
right now about what happens to
even those who have become naturalized
citizens if they have lied in any way to
gain citizenship but the government
rarely pursues these Liars unless
they're somehow involved in war crimes
or terrorism but you Trump you want to
expand prosecution of those who have
worked here illegally like say perhaps a
26 year old woman who was reported by
The Associated Press on Friday night to
have been here in 1996 on a visitor's
visa and yet worked here illegally paid
for ten modeling assignments that were
not permitted under her visa having
violated immigration rules Trump she
later became a citizen if she tried this
on your first day after you take over
the government
you would presumably prosecute her and
revoke her citizenship and send her out
of the country you may know her story
she is your wife and her story is a lie
another lie another [ __ ] trump lie
that's the closure I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space